hi
um welcome everyone uh to this evening's
meetup um thank you all for attending
um so um just a brief introduction about
pi data
pi data is a program by num focus and
it's focused uh
to bring a community to
anyone who's interested or developing a
data analyst
related to our project
and it's aimed to
anyone in general who's interested in
python and data um this pi data chapter
in riyadh
is organized by um
um daniel dorsey uh robert maruti and
myself
abdullah and
and this evening uh we have abdul rahman
for example
is a system engineer at facebook and
he's a contributor to the apache
spark project um is going to talk about
um ml flow and open source
uh machine learning life cycle platform
um it's worth noting that this
talk is going to be around 50 minutes
and followed by 18 minute 10 minutes for
q a please use the q a functionality
on zoom to submit your questions and
we'll
get we'll get to them at the end of the
talk
um and once again thank you all for
attending
um off to your other
all right thank you thank adela
um let's become the host
all right well uh somebody come everyone
um and good morning
good evening depending uh depending on
are
i'm currently based in california so
it's 11 in the morning
uh it's good to talk to all of you i
hope inshallah this will be a
productive workshop or session and
looking forward to hearing your
questions in the channel
so let me share my screen so we have
actually we have slides and
demo we're going to split this
presentation or this workshop
between the two
yeah just one second
here's one second till i share my screen
all right
all right because now we can i'm hoping
everyone can see the screen
um if not please um message me and i'll
take a look um so again yeah let's
uh did you get a talking shot we're
gonna talk about ml flow
um mflow is an open platform uh for
machine learning learning life cycle
and i'm going to explain what this what
this means that the word is very packed
um we'll go through through all of the
components and the motivation behind
this framework
um uh i guess maybe a brief intro um
abdullah did uh um
a bit more um so yeah i've been a
systems engineer at facebook for uh the
past three and a half years
working on um mostly apache spark
which is another open source framework
for um distributed cluster computing
framework
um as well as data engineering data
science work applied machine learning
and so on
so it's been very um very productive a
few years at facebook and
certainly learned a lot from um from
leaders in the field when it comes to
the analytics or
when it comes to applying machine
learning or um
to open source uh tools uh facebook is
one of the
top contributors to a lot of open source
frameworks and i personally find this
very intriguing and motivating so
i hope you guys will share this uh
motivation and vision with me
um all right so um
we're gonna cover four topics um first
we'll be talking about the
machine learning pipeline life cycle
um as well as the machine learning
development challenges
like uh what are the top three
issues that people face in development
either enterprise or at personal level
um and then we can actually introduce ml
flow and do a demo on it
so yeah so i'm going to spend some time
actually explaining
the issues that the industry faces or
what they used to face
and why ml flow emerges the solution
and where it fits
um all right so first yeah let's talk
about the machine learning
pipeline lifecycle or or what is a
simple pipeline look like
um in practice
so uh this is a simple chart
um for for an absolute it's an abstract
chart for
a typical machine learning pipeline as
in any um at any enterprise
this one in particular came from a paper
published by facebook
but the same idea actually applies to
any industry or adding
any enterprise application pretty much
every
um every machine pipeline always or
machine learning in general always
starts with data
the assumption is data exists um what
has been collected beforehand
um and there is all um
and then that the question comes after
um once you have sufficient data
collection about any metric
like in this case or you can take this
example in particular
um facebook news feed
uh some of you as you know as most of
you are familiar because with this with
this application
uh facebook injects ads and a lot of um
in their facebook application or
instagram ads
um and um and they
as part of feedback loop they collect
information about the engagement
of these ads and by engaging we're
talking about
a like to like or comment or
share or even just stopping the scroll
and looking at the
these all count as engagements so um
assuming that you have some
infrastructure in place where you're
logging these metrics you're logging the
likes the comments
engagements shares and whatnot um
after some time then you're trying to
the question comes
could you use this engagement data to
try to predict which ads will become
more
um engaging ideally you would show ads
only for people who are going to engage
with it
so um
the step one of the data collection is
always
predates um and kind of the requirement
for any pipeline now once the error is
collected
um then the first actually the first
kind of data science work starts
um mostly in the future engineering um
in the future engineering practice so uh
rhodia rodera is on its own is
not only useful so it takes some sort of
transformation to make it
to turn it into features which can be
actually used for training
yeah i'm not going to go deep into what
features look like this is another talk
but simply data to feature
to feature transformation is is a data
it's called the future engineering work
and it's very it's very typical of data
scientists
to spend some time extracting features
that you think they're useful
or that they you the su they think there
is problem
problems behind it now once features are
collected
um the third step will the obvious one
is training
using the you know picking a model
architecture
trying different features and different
parameters so i'm doing in training
and training is also um well it's not a
singular step but there's a lot of
feedback going on
you train multiples multiple uh
multiple models trying to improve and we
can get
you know the best performance and once
you have a good performing model
then you ship it um and you actually use
it for production and that's called
influence
so you could see this pipeline is
spending the two half there's online and
offline
the the online section on the right um
is the the real time the real time
the real-time system so when you have an
inference it's usually done at
online level so as someone is using the
app we are getting added real time
um and so is the feedback collection
but the rest of the pro there is the
components data collection feature
engineering our training
is done offline um could be daily or
weekly or monthly
as it suits the model so as a high level
this is what a
machinery pipeline looks like what i
would emphasize on here is the feedback
loop
it starts from data and it ends with the
predictions but always goes back
and use the new data and try to improve
and explain why this is important
um so yeah so um
now the same yeah similar summary so we
just saw the feedback
between data and deployment this outer
loop is very important
to maintain
to maintain a model performance that's
that keeps up with the changes of
people's behavior um
this is the outer feedback loop there is
also another feedback loop that's in
that's you know internal which is which
concerns more
uh data scientists or developers
uh which is going back within features
and evaluation this smaller loop in the
middle
this loop is usually
it's kind of a core feedback loop and
it's much faster like it's done at
the iterations that happen here are much
much higher frequency
and it involves a lot of tweaking and
testing and experimenting
and our focus will be actually more of
this internal loop
between future engineering and
evaluation or training
and we'll try to you know we'll try to
explain why this loop matters a lot and
what is actually challenging with it
um so so that
yeah now that we got an overview what uh
what the life cycle looks like
and from uh from a high level
um let's look at to uh look into a few
um
a few machine learning development
challenges that people face and then
that's really at personal level
um so first
okay well this chart might be a bit
overwhelming but actually this diagram
came from a paper
uh called hidden technical that's um in
machine learning systems uh
they were published in in nurembus um
in van nurbs conference uh by actually
uh
by a team of google engineers uh
what what they want to highlight here um
is the middle section here so you could
see actually what
what the what this paper trying to
explain is that often like
it's often the case that machine core
machine learning work
by core i mean um we mean
like the model algorithms the algorithms
that power the
the model training and also other few
more things
only make up a very small part of the
whole overall picture
so we can actually see this ml code ml
code section or a box
it's relatively small in size compared
to the rest of the surrounding
components
like their verification or collection
collection is actually a big step that
requires a lot of infrastructure a lot
of effort to do
analysis is a big one monitoring is also
a big once you have a model you ship it
monitoring the performance the model
actually is very important too
to prevent users from
from either seeing the incompatible ads
or
or being driven away from the service
because the
with the predictions you are making are
very off
um so what people think that the
exciting part of machine learning is
actually very small
um like writing the the model itself or
the model code um
the rest of components that surround the
machine learning
ecosystem um are actually a lot of them
um
and they are a pain for pretty much
every you know
pain to deal with or to manage a lot of
fragmentation
um as you saw before there's like five
there are five segments in the machinery
five
and a life cycle so a lot of tooling
that serves every section
so it's uh fairly interconnected and
fragmented um so that's just another
review what you know what machining is
it's not
simply writing the pipeline code but
there is a lot more to it than just that
and we'll see why um in a minute
all right so um i'm going to summarize
three mission level three challenges in
development
uh a big one that i that we uh pretty
much every
most of you maybe have faced i
personally used to face this a lot too
and i still do
which is the the issue of
reproducibility
you could always write this one pipeline
using keras or
by torch or scikit-learn
and you will do you know use some data
you train a model
um and get some results but then you
come next day or next week and you
really and just restart the notebook
again
and all of a sudden the model you
actually you that you
end up with the second time performs
differently could be worse could be
better
and you try to restart the model again
and you end up with different results
every time
so model training is not
it's not well usually it's not a
deterministic process so
there are some variables a lot of a lot
of initial um
a lot of initial conditions or initial
state conditions can be random
and that could lead to actually
completely different models especially
let's see random forest trees or so
so it's really uh reproducing a model is
actually an often a challenge
um which might lead to results being um
being inconsistent another part of the
experimentation is parametering so
um a lot of pretty much every model that
you
work with will require some initial
conditions or assumptions
um cool for a tree the depth of the tree
even for deep learning um
like what is a learning rate is one
high parameter it could be the number of
hidden layers
so a lot of parameters that change
between experiments and it's often a
pain to keep track of these
um um especially like if you have a
python file or python script
you could use you know one variable like
there's one value for a variable but
then you
also on a notebook and you end up with a
model but then you try different one
and it's hard to go back to the original
one because you already tried something
else
so these two issues are basically
reproducibility is often a challenging
uh aspect of uh pipeline development
because really sometimes you want to go
back and compare your results to
something you tried last week
but often times they didn't have access
to that so that's one big challenge
that pretty much anyone who writes a
pipeline deals with
another one uh models stillness
by model stainless what i mean here is
modeling the model getting old so maybe
you can
this could be clear if they contrast it
with mention of software engineering so
uh with software you could you know um
write a script or build
a website or write a binary and then you
publish and then
and that's it maybe you could make
updates and fixes and release the next
one the future
um but in the meanwhile the app will
perform the same way
um until you know the new release is
made or
produced but for machine learning
actually that's not
often the case what happens is if you
even if you just make it you know if you
um if you have
if you have picked the right model with
the right data and you train them
a good model you optimize it to the best
um
to the best parameters you could the
models on their own will actually get
worse over time because
the data that you use to train them are
no longer fresh
they are no longer representative of the
user behavior or the user actions
so often pipelines need to be
always rerun or updated on daily or
or weekly basis to keep up with the
data freshness as you recall from the
first slide we had this
feedback loop we have you know we have
your log data
uh and then you kick the training again
this loop is always
pretty much continuous it's um
continuously triggered so you always
have you and you always end up with
with a with a model that's always up to
date
and as an example of stillness um
there's also from uh from
training training training sequences at
facebook
so uh some model like a news feed i'll
actually train
uh i read three and again in a matter of
minutes
because the recall news feed is pretty
much the
change it could easily change
in a matter of minutes maybe a new topic
might show up a new hashtag or a new um
a new like breaking news might take over
so you have to always be up to date and
capture the
latest trends error so and newsfeed
models actually done
are trained very frequently uh such
models also in
ours because of new terms uh language
language models like translation or
summarization
um models are three in the matter you
know weeks days or weeks
um the language is not changed that fast
but it's still you want to keep up with
the latest
um latest slang or latest words that
people are actually adding
lastly the face face solution models
that are the most
uh the least trained ones uh maybe a
matter of months
uh people's faces don't change as often
like it there that still does not change
the face itself the same
so we don't have to train as much as
frequently
so that's one yeah one yeah but the
common factor is
there is always a loop um uh it's
similar the case we train once and
and you forget um pretty much you have
to keep updating the model
but the question is how frequent i can
range from minutes or hours to weeks
some months
uh another challenge a third one that's
also um maybe matters more for
for uh enterprise users or enterprise
customers
which is the issue of uh putting um
going from development to production so
it's often easy that you could write a
pipeline in python
in a notebook or in a python file but
actually you
putting that model into use like for a
case of inference
is another challenge because you have
first
there's level the production environment
is often different it's not the same
notebook you're using anymore
also a lot of uh performance a lot of
performance aspects are
start and start to matter
when development performance doesn't
matter as much because it's um
there's no penalty for latency but for
blockchain cases if you are browsing an
app or let's say instagram or
facebook and it takes a second to load
them through the new ad
that might lead for people actually
leaving the app and actually not using
it
so uh latency and performance matter a
lot more production
than development which means the
environments are different so that's
often a challenge to design for both and
try to minimize the difference between
the two um
so yeah the uh so that's basically you
know it's a recap of the three
challenges we discussed so yeah it seems
like the development is hard well
a lot of issues with development and
that's it used to be worse
it has it hasn't uh has gotten better
and
uh one reason is ml flow so
mf flow actually was uh was conceived by
uh or by as my uh
uh whatever i um i'll get started by uh
by a startup or a company called airbrex
which one of the contributors to
spark so into actually 2017 uh 2017 the
mlf law was actually first released
um at the spark summit uh edinburgh was
there in
the conference so the primary focus or
the primary motivation behind emma flow
is literally to address that the
development channels you just mentioned
um so let's learn let's talk more about
mflo and why
and how it will help so um first thing
in my flow is a python library
open source um uh with with more than
100 contributors
um the goal of it is to simplify few
aspects of machine learning life cycle
machine learning life cycle or pipeline
life cycle is actually you know
it's fairly large and extendable um like
five steps but
mflo tries to capture and um deal with
the
with a smaller feedback loop that we're
going to see in a minute in a bit
the nice thing about flow is very
extendable and integrates with a lot of
the frameworks that everyone uses
scikit-learn python tensorflow has a
good ui for tracking
and visualizations became very popular
in the last year and a half
almost a million downloads a lot of
contributors to it
um so um what is it yeah where does it
come with
so there are a few components and that's
still actually there is a fourth
component
that was actually just added to the
framework but the three main ones
actually the
less the tracking projects and modeling
so
tracking probably was the one that maybe
would we're going to spend more time on
today
but simply what tracking it means here
is simplifying
the experimentation with pipelines um
you know
an experiment or machine learning or not
uh involves a lot of bookkeeping and
tracking of bibles
so it's really easy to miss and lose
track of of the experiment
which might lead to
inconsistent results or just or or a
failed failed job basically so
the better tracking of an experiment the
more likely you'll end up with a high
fidelity
result that you're more confident with
so that's the first module
um the tracking um
the tracking project there's also the
project
projects one which another utility of
mflow
that allows allows any user to package
their model into um
to to a platform agnostic format that
you can ship
and run across any other platform
another environment
talk about running locally running the
cloud like an aws sagemaker
uh gcp or azure ml
i like to require a few environments now
even for a cloud too
um keeping things consistent working
across them is a challenge and that's
one of the things that um
has to focus on there's also the
modeling one
uh which which deals with the serving
one once you trained and optimized them
all they're going to serve it
and containerize it so um that's what
that's another feature
um or another component that mfo offers
today we're going to focus actually more
on tracking it's one of the first
is the most like it's important and the
first um
first actually component to be added to
mflow um
so let's see more a little more about
the tracking and why is it uh
what it actually do so um before we go
to the demo we're going to talk a few
small things so
uh simply in a machine learning
experiment a few things that you track
usually are
there are high parameters um key value
pairs
um for example there's uh for the three
years there's the three depth
uh number of iterations the learning
rate
um they're quite a lot of these it could
be a number of written layers in a deep
network
neural network so um those refer to high
parameters
and also metrics which means they
actually measure it for every
uh training iteration so uh accuracy or
recall or area of the curve um quite few
metrics that apply different models so
these are referred to
by metrics which things that you use to
compare models performers
um against each other it becomes very
handy
in the ui which we'll kind of show the
demo there's also artifacts so um
essentially once you three a model you
have a binary file that holds the
weights
or the encoding for the model so that's
one of the outputs you have
this binary file you also have you could
have some metadata
some visualizations and others we can
look at these as well as the source code
so uh yeah so we attract the input
outputs and also and also by and also by
product so
that's kind of what goes into an
experiment um and
yeah the nfl offers a tracking server so
we can actually
we're going to go we're going to look at
this in the demo um
but basically what mf flow gives you um
gives you is a
an api interface
that you can plug with any experiment to
log the metrics you care for
and then visualize them and compare them
later and that could be
you could log from local experiments and
see if the results to some database in
the cloud and visualize it
so um very flexible and extendable
um all right so uh
[Music]
finally before we demo yeah we're gonna
focus so uh the the component we just
looked at
is the ml flow tracking deals with
simplifying this
uh this segment so the ml flow sorry or
ml lifecycle
actually is very wide it goes from data
to deployment
but a lot of it's often painful enough
to deal with the training and evaluation
one
this feedback loop is very often the
most demanding one
from data scientists and users
yeah mflo does not solve the issue of
data management and data governance or
data versioning these are other big
challenges a lot of other products
trying to solve it
uh mflo is not focused on the data one
um recently they had expanded more the
deployment one
so try to offer deployment uh model
serving so um
yeah i guess there over time we're gonna
uh so you know try to cover more and
more of this uh this life cycle
all right finally there's some
information here and it's not only to um
actionable but um the size mlf.org
um as we said like almost a million
downloads monthly
um there's also a managed demo flow
services and in their brakes and azure
offers it
um if you do wanna install it and deal
with it you can always
use the cloud version um
all right so on that we looked at the um
it's a theoretical part of this of the
workshop we're going to
go into a demo so let me stop sharing
and open the
notebook
there's gonna be some four questions uh
please write that way let me look at the
questions maybe
i could answer that um
yeah we look at the questions at the end
um i'm having some of them for sure i
actually want to spend a good time with
them but yeah
let me go to the modeling section and do
a demo
so we could
all right
yeah i see your questions um i can see
them and we'll get to them in a bit
nice
animations
i'm just going to share the screen and
try to share the cursor so you guys can
see it
all right as you can see yeah yeah i
suppose you can see my screen if you
if you cannot see it or if you have
issues it's too small you can write in
the
messages and i will adjust
if i need to be
all right so um this is a notebook
actually reversed one um
uh recently another this will be all
published the slides and the notebook
will be published
publicly says all can see it um
and let me just gonna we're gonna go
through and explain it um so we actually
understand what we do here
so uh i'm using google cool app
notebooks um
all business cloud um
so let's go through this so yeah
these sections are not really too
important so every cell
google drive mount importing libraries
um very standard things and here is the
nsn
so first actually let's look at the data
set see what we are you know what the
what this name was about so yeah this
demo is actually about mflow
but mflow is is a library for machine
learning so
it cannot just demo mf flow on its own
um we'll have to do some
um use of you know use some model and
data and modeling and then use the
memory flow on top to show how it helps
with experimentation so yeah so uh
pretty much
two-thirds of this notebook is is a
normal
um machine learning modeling case
there's a few uh machine learning ml
flow uh part of it which we're gonna
explain
but yeah cyberflow is assumes you have a
working
machine learning training um example it
adds on top of it
can you zoom in a bit more sure yeah
i will zoom in further actually
but yeah i i certainly want this to be
readable
yeah i think this is good yeah thank you
okay yeah thank you
all right i just want to search my hand
for once okay
all right so we continue um
[Music]
so yeah this notebook is most of us
mostly it's a it's a standard um
modeling uh pipeline and there is the
additional ember flow
sections i'll go through these so um
the first thing we're going to go
through is the data so let me just know
the data set that i
picked this uh some open data that i
found on university of uh here's the
california airport website
that's a bike sharing dataset um so let
me
briefly explain what this is so this
data set has
um um has records of a bike sharing
system think of a a rentable bike um
rack so um there is that i think iraq in
irvine or somewhere i don't want
i'm not sure which kind of city is it
but it's a company that
owns and rents bikes by an hour and they
collect the
um about um about their other usage
so what they do um what the data has
uh they have a date the season the year
the month
time whether it's a holiday or not a
weekday or not
also they have weather information what
the weather was that hour
temperature humidity wind speed and most
importantly
this one is the number of total
uh total bikes rented
so um they're tracking how many bikes
they rented by the hour and also
tracking the
um environmental environmental variables
um also uh yeah a temporal
environment um and the
question is try to build a model that
could predict
how many bikes will be rented given
um given the day and the weather
conditions
um so let me show an example what this
looks like it would be easier so we had
my birthday now just
extracting it and loading it to a daily
frame
so the user there looks like so simply
[Music]
actually let me show you with the clean
up there
is
so this is the post cleaning let me just
so what it looks like yeah this is what
it looks like so season so we have one
so the season is uh
ranges from zero to four to three so uh
spring fall
autumn and winter a year zero means 2012
uh one week of 13 so it's over two years
the experience in the
in the in the website
month uh 1 to 12
of the day range from zero to 24 to 23
so 24 hours
uh other symbolian columns so is the
holiday or not
what weekday is it is it a working day
or not
uh because you could have uh well um i
guess holiday and working day are
mutually exclusive
um but you could have you could have a
monday that's a holidays that's why they
want to know
it with a workday like some national
holidays might fall into a weekday
so anyway these are information about
the
day of the rental there is a weather
situation too
let's go range from one to four and they
explain it here
um so um
here's the number so one cleo means
clear
two missed three is light snow falls
every
so what is the best four is ours in
terms of weather or biking
uh temperature is normalized
and so this also feels like temperature
and also humidity and wind
and finally rendered bikes this is how
many bikes you added to that tower so
um if we take this in a row for instance
um
this rose is for a season one
which is for in 2012 january
and um
three in the morning it's not a holiday
weather was okay temperature was fine
they rented 32 by except however that's
what it means
um so a very a fairly simple data set uh
quite a lot of pipelines use it
um and here are the rules look like so
yeah there were
a handful of features which is useful
for modeling
um
we can do some simple gear exploration
so um
we can plot um the
mechanism
total rented bikes by hourly day so we
have
23 hours in a day um so you could tell
maybe there's some people renting at
midnight
um you can see like in the morning seven
eight
uh eight in the morning the peak um and
then we have some you know well later in
the morning
where you get to work we stop renting
then you have afternoon
and probably 5 p.m is another peak when
people rent wipes again
and then it just declines until the
later and then through the day
so um seems very intuitive people rent
bikes you know
early in the morning before work and
also right after work
so that's one feature the outer day and
there are quite a lot of them
so um the question is yeah i try to
build a model
that that estimates or those or
[Music]
models the number of bikes sent it by
all the features just mentioned
so now we have a data set which we uh uh
what you're going to do is we
obviously want to split the two sections
there is the training and
uh and testing um and there is also
i'm using the standard um
using standard functions to that so 70
30 is the rule of thumb
um so we have 30 percent of data using
you know
and testing and 17
and here i'm defining the input and
outputs so where uh next is the
input for the training which is
everything except the output fiber which
is the rented bikes
the output is um as someone the
predicted um
entity is the rented bikes so um they're
using pretty simple scikit-learn
um terminology here so we have a split
um here we have you know 14
almost uh actually quite a lot
um other than 140k
training samples which is quite good um
now here is what though whatever email
flow starts now we have a data split so
now we're done with step one
having data that's collected is cleaned
up pre-processed
organized inputs and outputs and testing
and
training so first that comes to mind
here is
uh well first thing we do is actually on
emma flow
um you first you do
have an experiment so you can do a
listen experiment for instance likes so
whatever phone i will know from now on
everything here will be about
the rented bikes um experiment
um very simple helpful methods you might
experience two which is a very simple
method that given a model they extract
some scores like the root mean squares
error
a very popular metric you capture from
money score
there's explanation for this there's
also cross-validation
score so um when you create a model you
you do not only you do not want to just
use the segment of training
um for the scoring when you use um you
can use the rest of training data to
to get an accurate measure of score um
which is here here is afraid by
cross-validation so let's explain what
this
cross-validation is but yeah what are
these what these functions do
they just basically they you give it a
model and then a train model
and they um count or collect um
performance metrics a while so we can
compare it to others
um now he has to have another help
another
helper method which is uh logging to
mlflow
so i'm a vlog expected to call it to
lock some metrics and hear what we're
doing here
i'm saying well for every run every run
i want to collect
some metrics that i have and in these
two dictionaries which we'll explain in
a second
but basically here with these what these
lines do these lines log the parameters
used so i'm telling
my flow and log these parameters and
these parameters are actually listed
right here
there's a number of estimators there's a
loss function there's a learning
rate and max depth
of these are the most important ones
that we care about so overflow i'm just
trying to track these ones and also i'm
trying to track
metrics which is which are the outputs
or the scores
um and here we have two scores or two uh
um two matrix there's a root mean square
very popular or very
popular score used for uh
benchmarking regression uh modeling
models
also here i'm saving the model itself uh
when you get to this well we'll see what
this will do in a minute but yeah
this code is fairly standard and it's
not special to this notebook
um you're watching the um you can find
the tutorial
territorial web page anyway so this is
the now we're getting yeah
yeah yeah we got this out of the way
it's called the parameters and before i
go to the parameters i'm going to make a
small thing so
i'm using scikit-learn library and i
picked
i already decided that they picked
ingredients boosting regressor
so
it's very powerful um representing
technique
so i'm using using decision trees for
regression
and using a boosting technique for those
now a lot of model models a lot of
techniques in them i already picked this
one
um based on based on
recommendations and prior experience
it's a fair question to say well which
model to use and which not
uh actually there's a there are guides
online that you know
you can follow and it will tell you
which model model architecture should
use
should you use a linear regression or
should you use the shin trees
uh by the way for the sake of the this
demo
we already picked this model time um
all right so what's going on so this
section is where things actually get
interesting it's the most important
section of this notebook
so what i'm doing here um so you have to
you can well let's look here
look at these two um two dictionaries so
you have the parameters dictionary
which has um you can see as well pretty
much
there's a fixed value of parameters
number of estimators
pretty much using that was the default
value using default values for all of
these
these are static variables they didn't
change what matters more is this one
grammar is great so every um
for every um decision tree
um there is a depth that you could
choose that will affect the performance
a lot
so uh what i'm trying to do here is i'm
trying to
uh where i'm going to experiment with i
wanna my experiment would cover all
these three
or four different depths i want to try
it three uh
three of the three four and five and six
and same time also i want to try
different learning rates which also
affect the performance i want to know
which one is very reverse um it's hard
to tell which one will be affecting
the model positively negatively that's
where the big questions are big
challenges in
machine learning today is at least in
the training section is
these higher parameters choosing the
right parameters and
no one really knows which parameters are
the correct ones so what you can do is
start experiments and then find the ones
by by experimentation i will see how
this i'm afraid help us
so um now here we're just draining the
experiments um so we're trying every
combination possible
um so we have three and four so we have
12 expenses
and three times four um so here you find
the model
we do a fit so that's where the training
section happens we're printing some
things
depending some parameters um and then
here is where we actually get the stats
about the performance
these are the scores that are going to
be used to compare the models across
each other
and once we saw we train we get the with
the training results and then we log in
to ml flow and we'll see what this
vlogging will look like
so around this like it takes a few
minutes fairly quick
and you can see a lot of iterations um
between these two and you can see well
this iteration had this uh
a loss ratio uh this one had a different
loss so you can see this one was a
this run was actually better than the
first one uh and third one was even
better
the fourth one was worse and so on and
so forth
um yeah then we don't have to try to you
know decode these values we're going to
use mf flow for this
all right so now that we did the
training um
uh let's yes we can look at the look at
the evaluation section so okay let me
start right here
and now i'm going to look at the open
the ml floor ui
so in the flow um also opens the ui in
the background you can access
um so let's go actually go and look at
it this is mf website
so here is the ml flow i have for the
experiments i just opened so
when i run when i run this um
this um this cell here this run 12
experiments and vlog
and they all got locked timer flow and
the background they had overflow
uh running so as i mentioned you know
flow comes with a nice ui the one you're
seeing
here what you're gonna explore um so
let's go through this a little bit yeah
so experiment so we have one experiment
here which is the length of x1
i'm really doing one experiment today uh
there's one category of experiments
um and here's what i'm doing so i have
these 12
experiments and now let's look at these
ones so
for each experiment i have a start time
so these are
today uh each experiment has a few
columns
these so training chose to log so
training size the same
same columns for each learning rate well
now we can see that learning rate is
actually different
for uh for each one
and also i think we can let me open the
um parameters so there's more parameters
than just this one
um so i guess we can show the ones that
we care about
so number of estimators so i think we
the ones we looked we
cared about is learning rate and max
death so let's just keep these this is
the one that mattered to us
remember to go back here these are the
two
parameters we actually experimented with
we had 12 experiments
um so yeah let's go back to the ui
so here is the value for the first
parameter and the value for the second
one
and here are the results for both so we
have 12 experiments and there's
therefore both and you could
so i will see that basically means the
lower that means
the error the error in the model in the
model so the lower the arm you see the
bar
um and the cross validation was just
stronger and it's a
stronger um at some coverage so
this is the metric we actually care
about them more than just a singular
rmse so let me even hide the other one
so i'm going to hide from google's
metrics i'm going to hire this rmc
all right now we have the inputs and the
outputs now actually these are the um
uh the numbers the performance numbers i
care about and if i click here actually
i can sort them
by you know up down so the lower the
variable
so what this tells me the best model
here is
the one that had length of zero zero
point one
and depth of six which is six uh well uh
six
um levels of a tree it had the best
uh the lowest error out of all of them
and not only that let's do even more
things let's do a comparison between
these two maybe look at the numbers at
all it's not easy but let's look
you know click on compare and see what
do we get here
all right well so we get another ui it's
actually it's quite full of things that
it might look overwhelming but let's
spend a second maybe
so same thing that we showed you just
show it in a typical format so you have
a start date and here's
each one so they're in one with any size
and you can see the highlighted ones are
the ones
that change between different brands and
here are the
results so what matters to me the most
is as
a developer
um what is the relationship between
learning rate and
and um and the error right
so well there's a simple
plot here we can do we can use scatter
plot so let's compare that let's look at
the learning rate
and look at the cross validation error
and we get this plot at that this
scatter plot here
uh learning rates in the x axis and the
error in the y axis
um so it looks like from what i can tell
here the higher the learning rate
the lower the error and that's evident
by these four dots
these four experiments each has
experiment uh it used the same learning
rate and they all had um
they all had lower error rate than the
rest so it means uh
the higher learning rate level so that's
good let me look at the other variable
now which is the
depth right well similarly it looks like
um
depth is universally powerful it's also
proportional
diversity much better so the higher the
tree the the higher three the more
levels
the lower the error so we can see this
one these ones here
they have the highest level of six
levels also they have the lowest
error rate among all of them now we're
looking at a lot of variables can we
visualize ultimate you know we can also
visualize it as a control a contour path
may make it easier
more like a 3d visualization so we're
plotting two variables
learning rate and max step these are the
two variables and then we're going to
compare the output
so from this one we can we can look at
this heat map
um it looks like we
as you go higher in the x-axis we get
lower error with
a lighter shade of blue and also if you
go higher
max that like even here we even get a
lower
uh error rate so maximizing learning
rate and
depth leads to a better model
um that's a pretty much as a conclusion
we are getting
uh listen to the last one this last plot
which might be a bit overwhelming but
this
this will explain what you know how the
inputs actually affect the output
so let me remove the the standard
terrestrial matter
so these are not related these
parameters are not something we're
actually experimenting with
all right so let's take a second and
dissect what this looks like so
[Music]
what you're looking at this will have
this first parameter which is a learning
day and we have
um a line a line is a line kind of takes
um
defines an experiment so each line here
is actually you have 12 lines
but well we can traverse 12 lives from
like one this is one
i'm here to hear that and also we have
this one
blue one all the way to the end so we
have twelve of these
but if i look at the output just the
validation where is the lowest so
blue is the lowest i have a look at the
bottom here
where do these lines come from well
looks like they all come from
uh depth of sex
and the lines in in depth of six seems
to come from
one song
higher you know the highest level grades
so if i traverse this line
uh which is the first the top one here
this uh this one here like zero point
one
two six this first one and also then you
can see it's the same line goes all the
bottom
maybe it's hard to see in my screen but
what what this plot is trying to show
is maximizing learning rate and next
step
leads to reduces the error the most
so that's one thing actually we're able
to tell from um
from mlflow's experiment tracking and if
you go back to this one here
we can sort by error and we can tell
this is the best one so what this
what this does is here max depth and of
6 and
negative 0 and 1 is the best so i could
in theory go here
and actually i can remove all the other
values
that i know it actually works like here
so now i'm using the right correct
variables that's for the
results of the experiment um so that's
one thing atmosphere helped with the
track and experiment the
last thing i'm going to show is uh
um other thing that the flow will keep
track of so
we're visualizing threes so we had
something interesting so you know future
importance you know some
some visualization of the models we
actually had so we can tell you that our
day is the most important feature of the
of our in our prediction there is an
another fewer you know it's not going to
detail these charts they're very
standard
uh because they're not more they're not
ml related but more of a
model um i'm also visualizing the three
here that reaction
we're using this is actually a three
that we're are that we picked for our
model
um but uh the thing i'm going to show
you actually is enamel flow still so let
me go with an experiment i'm going to
pick this experiment
and click on it and it will actually
zoom and it'll show me more information
about that singular
run same parameters are used
generate the outputs
but the most interesting part actually
is here the artifacts
so mflo keeps track of the of the output
data and also visualization so
i don't remember there is a future
important chart so i can actually
understand easily where this model is
about them compared to others so
this is this is the future importance
chart for this model i can also click on
them
another chart here solution you can
click on the
decision tree itself which is
um if you want to visualize the results
and how you get you know how you can
traverse the outputs and references from
this one
so uh mflo is tracking all the variables
actually in here
so yeah
i'm afraid we're about uh we're almost
out of time
actually i'm done with the demo
yeah i'm actually done for the demo part
and i will go back to the questions
um that you guys uh answered so
let me stop you understand as i
mentioned this will go and published so
don't worry about uh not uh seeing it
um cool thank you abraham for this
interesting talk um
uh we'll take a few questions just for
the q a part
um so this question is uh to avoid model
stain
stillness do we need to re retrain the
model
um are there any standards regarding
that part
how frequent and when to do it
yeah so for the avoiding stainlesses you
can really open the
so stainless is an issue that happens
with even you know it happens on its own
even without um
without actually any uh
[Music]
an interaction of data so um basically
stainless is a function of
of how fresh your data is so if you're
not ethereum
your data will basically get still
so the solution is to continuously read
in your
um thermos only three
your model um other standards right
there's a frequency so
um there are no set standards but it's
basically you want to you want to
maintain
the same velocity as uh the data
the how that the data fundamentally
changes so a news feed is mentioned it's
done
in minutes because you know news can be
trending in minutes notice
phase phase signature models are done in
months or years
because people's spaces don't change
that fast so frequency is depends on the
data
the nature there itself um so yeah model
status is avoided by retraining
frequency is is based on the nature oh
it's more
yeah it's more um nature data nature
isn't related
so um yes that's a question and i think
that i get a key
question um so
next other question is how to how to
deal with
with uh poisoning your data
so you have a similar questions how
example okay facebook decides to show
or not based on similar glacier
[Music]
all right so um i guess poisoning so
poisoning sounds
more malicious or intentional but let me
put it away so
in the previous i'm gonna show you the
slide actually
[Music]
so and uh if you remember the
pre-processing
i'm gonna share the screen
[Music]
here so in terms of poisoning or
education so in the data pre-processing
where like post
when you have log data i usually do some
you know kind of
uh you still pre-process it which means
you apply some heuristic functions like
this you know simply you could tell
um like for example like maybe in case
of facebook if you have
1000 likes you know per hour from one
user
you could easily you know detect this
anomaly and reject
these logs um so basically you can avoid
uh anomaly avoid the
extreme data by doing some anomaly
detections or anomaly corrections and
avoidance
and also data conditioning so you have
some sets of mins and maxes
for each feature that you expect and you
condition it here too
so it's a pre-training step before you
train you apply the
preconditioning procedures which is
finding anomalies and removing them
uh minutes and maxes if someone likes a
photo
like no human can make a million likes
an hour
so we can always set a max and eject
everything above
like that so yeah there is always a new
one
there is expected set of uh values and
there's also extremes you can also use
the percentiles
like you know reject one person like the
99th percentile above
you can assume as anomalous and rejected
and so
so yeah the question is you basically
deal with it statistically
um yeah member floor is not really
helped with this part
it assumes the data is really clean and
pre-processed
like guess yeah that's a question for me
i can read them myself
do i read them or share it to myself um
we would like them announced to the to
the
audience if they can't see them yeah i
was gonna read it myself but you can
read it
okay um so this is a question regarding
this slide actually uh can you do
feature selection training and
et cetera through the platform um
mfloor does not uh today directly help
with that um
so i think that when mflo was released
2017 um
so actually 2018. uh it was 2018 was
released in
june uh the first thing i see through
exactly is improving
um just doing the tracking experiment
tracking the parts just going through in
the
in the notebook which is a more extreme
evaluation
cycle features were not um
feature engineering were or were not
it's not something that shouldn't
flow helps with today um however there
are
there are other libraries that do help
with improving and
making selection easy um there's a
an open source feature store uh python
library that helps with
uh synthesizing and uh
generating features so emma flow does
not directly
contribute but you can integrate with
you know with um
you can do your feature energetic step
uh
before mflow uh before demo flow is an
invoked
um it's very announcement chemical is
fairly extendable and
it does not only assume a lot about your
pipeline so you can let's just integrate
the
intersections where it matters wherever
you need it
so yeah okay so similarly
like data versioning and conditioning is
something that's not managed lambda flow
you know a lot of the pipeline has a lot
of uh
challenges in each of the sections so
i'm first trying to focus on the very
few
um primarily training evaluation and
deployment
uh maybe the few i'm thinking the future
is expanding to cover more of these
so not today in the future probably yes
cool um so if we have a
if we do an experiment and we want that
experiment again um does emerald flow uh
guarantee the same
the same results well so
no it would not necessarily guarantee
the same results because it
um you could be using and let's say if
you use a random forest
um if you're eaten in likely you could
be ending on different
different states but what the mfl will
help you with
it will track all the inputs and outputs
of that one so
let's say it will not prevent
um so mf law in itself would not prevent
uh end deterministic models but actually
it can help you make them deterministic
uh what i mean by this is uh mflo can
track
let's say the the seating numbers that
you use for your
random forest tree so if you use the
same seed
you could end up with under the same
three every time so
um info help you track these numbers and
then recall them in the future
so you're always using that you know the
parameters that will
ensure you uh you end up with the same
three so uh let's say mflow enables you
to track
the right metrics that allows you to be
deterministic
uh that's kind of the right answer uh
but i'm afraid it's all would not
if you just you know if you import it it
will not only
make your model interesting um you have
to integrate um
you know you have to kind of track the
models and if you uh
track all the inputs that you have a
model then
you will end up with a domestically
reproducible model
so yeah the answer is yes if you do the
integrations
um so this is a question so i understand
that ml flow is used to maintain and
document the ml pipeline
um can it be extended to automate some
stages of it
yes well so
the automation part will so a deployment
for instance except
it could help with packaging and
creating containers for instance
i guess this part we're going to cover
today but it's one of the
uh one of the other three components of
our flow
but uh it so yeah the answer is
partially yes
but to automate um the life cycle the
complete one the different tools are
used
and particularly there's another tool
another popular tool so uh
apache airflow
airflow actually is more of the
automation tool it's it's not machine
learning specific it's very agnostic
but mflo used with ml flow
because airflow and mlf flow used
together
you can automate the life cycle and also
drag experiments so each component does
one thing
and and these tools these two frameworks
and
can help um sample with each other
so yeah so automation partially for the
deployment
but to deploy the whole section which is
their extraction features deployment
and training like actually running naval
flow at some
this is done by another service
lookup air flow
it's another popular open source
framework that that's exactly what you
uh
what you just mentioned exciting
um so i think this is this would be the
last question
um are you planning another webinar
about amazon project
uh we could do one i mean i'm happy to
do another one i guess and uh
deployment at inference um i guess we
could be a quit
um maybe to organize something you know
and
next month uh more of deployment
evaluation
um cool so i guess yes so
that's our time we i might forward the
rest of the questions to you after ahmad
and we might post them on meetup
um on
on the meet the page or on twitter and
always
have it for
and looking forward to continuing this
one in the
what's
future
hey
okay